géographique à ce qui émane est
aujourd'hui les phénomènes karstiques
une définition pour commencer le casse
tous les phénomènes karstiques en fait
ce sont les résultats de l'érosion
hydrique et chimique des roches
principalement des roches calcaires donc
des roches carbonatées
vous retrouverez le schéma général de
ces différents phénomènes à la page 30
du syllabus du coup les autres surfaces
whissell en surface des roches qui ne
sont pas karstique
mais quand j'arrive sur un terrain
calcaire ça va changer donc là sur le
schéma regardez bien tout ce qui est ici
c'est du terrain qui n'est pas calquer
renom karstique
et là où c'est vers évidemment on est
sur des roches calcaires
une fois que mon cours d'eau arrivent
sur le terrain calcaire
qu'est ce qu'il va faire mais il ya une
érosion qui va être beaucoup plus
importante
donc vous voyez ici à droite du schéma
le cours d'eau la rivière va creuser
véritablement la roche calcaire jusqu'à
arriver à certains mais un niveau ou à
les stabiliser et se creuse m'envoyer
qui est assez impressionnant c'est ce
qu'on appelle des canyon ou des gorges
vous avez ici une illustration de ce
qu'est une gorge
il peut même carrément que en arrivant
sur le terrain calcaire l'eau
disparaissent en profondeur donc elle va
s'écouler dans des des réseaux
souterrains et va ressortir un certain
moment l'endroit où elle disparaît c'est
ce qu'on appelle une perte ou un chat
noir en se fasse on va vous remarquer
que l'eau disparaît dans un trou et
passe on ne sait évidemment elle est
dans le sol dans la roche calcaire sur
toute la longueur de son écoulements
souterrains l'eau finalement va former
comme une vallée sèche voyez ici sur la
photo g l'écoulement souterrain qui va
quand même creusé le relief meilleur
aucune eau en se fasse d'où le nom bien
portée de van est sèche
un certain moment ces eaux qui
s'écoulent dans la roche calcaire de
façon souterraine vont ressortir
c'est ce qu'on appelle une résurgence ou
un exutoire donc généralement l'eau
ressort un certain endroit et cet
endroit ça va souvent correspondre avec
un changement de type de roche
parce que par exemple on va tomber sur
des roches qui sont imperméables et à ce
moment là
ben l'on est obligé d'être hostile si
vous voulez à l'endroit où l'eau ressort
à l'endroit de la résurgence évidemment
l'eau va recommencer à éroder tout le
calcaire en surface et on va avoir
l'apparition d'un plateau en recul et
donc sur le schéma c'est assez clair ici
sur la photo on peut imaginer que la
résurgence est ici et elle va creuser
évidemment tous est en arc de cercle
tout le relief calcaire une résurgence
ou un exutoire c'est pour une rivière
souterraine qui ressort mais il se peut
aussi que dans la roche qui est
simplement les eaux d'infiltration donc
ce sont des eaux 1 qui pénètre la roche
mais de manière très diffus saint moins
importante et qui vont former des
réseaux souterrains et instantanément
ses taux quand elle va arriver face à
une roche différentes qui ne lui permet
pas de passer elle va ressortir en
surface de manière beaucoup moins
spectaculaire c'est ce qu'on appelle une
source vauclusienne évidemment les eaux
souterraines vont creuser la roche
calcaire en même temps que les eaux
d'infiltration
donc je vais avoir l'apparition de
différentes cavités dans la roche
calcaire c'est ce qu'on appelle les
grottes
évidemment à ce moment les groupes
peuvent être encore sous l'eau mais
l'eau peut passer à un étage inférieur
si vous voulez et donc ce qui va faire
que je vais avoir des grottes qui vont
être asséchés qui sont plus hautes que
les grottes qui sont encore sous l'eau
qui sont plus basses il arrive dans
certaines régions que le toit de la
grotte s'effondre j'ai toute cette zone
si qui s'affaisse et qui descend d'un
niveau alors j'ai l'apparition du
doline de l'insee vraiment un trou dans
le sol mais qui s'effondre sur le schéma
c'est ici il y en a en belgique 1 c'est
un phénomène assez courant alors quand
il ya plusieurs de ligne qui se
regroupent
comme sur la deuxième photo on parle à
ce moment-là de ou valve à une doline
c'est quand le toit de la grotte
s'effondre mais que ça reste fermé si
tout s'effondre et qu'on voit vraiment
un gouffre à paraître c'est ce qu'on
appelle un navet annabelle défendre mans
enfin un dernier phénomènes karstiques
c'est quand la roche de surface est
érodée et laisse apparaître finalement
que quelques gros bloc c'est ce qu'on a
ici c'est ce qu'on appelle un art bien
alors évidemment si vous avez une doline
dans toute votre maison ça pose problème
donc le calcaire et les phénomènes
karstiques le kart
selon des risques naturels c'est pour
cette raison que l'ensemble des pays
généralement qui ont du calcaire dans
leur sol constitue un atlas du caire
voyez ici je vous ai fait un capture
d'écran de la classe du cast wallon qui
permet de voir où se situent les
différents risques liés à la présence de
roches calcaires dans le sol
il n'est pas rare de voir dans la presse
locale des situations où des habitations
ou des personnes ont été mises en danger
en raison d'apparitions d'une demi
c'était le cas ici apple voyez qu'on se
pose la question de la présence de 2000
cette vidéo est finie ce que je vous
demande de faire pour le prochain coup
c'est de répondre au questionnaire qui
est en dessous de la vidéo sur ben logeo
vous devez bien sûr connaître un petit
peu tout ce qui vient d'être dit donc si
vous ceci nous sommes quelque chose que
vous n'avez pas compris
si les noms vous sont encore un petit
peu inconnu
regardez encore une nouvelle fois la
vidéo parce que vous jugement délirant
de reconnaître différents différent car
voilà à bientôt et bon travail